if a country has a great positive image
like germany has or sweden or
switzerland everything is easy and
everything is cheap you get more
tourists you get more investors you sell
your products more expensively we don't
admire countries primarily because
they're rich because they're powerful
because they're successful because
they're modern because they're
technologically technologically advanced
we primarily admire countries that are
good
this is a country which simply gives
more to humanity than anything any any
other country i don't talk about how
they behave at home because that's
measured elsewhere
and the winner is
ireland
no country on earth per head of
population per dollar of gdp
contributes more to the world that we
live in than ireland what does this mean
this means that as we go to sleep at
night all of us in the last 15 seconds
before we drift off to sleep our final
thought should be
god damn it i'm glad that ireland exists
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so brand irish it's a mystery it
genuinely is a mystery oh we have been
trading off this brand for some time now
haven't we
ireland's a funny place
our actual true gift is for
self-mythologizing the irish are the
funniest people
on the planet we can self-mythologize
our ability to self-pathologize
the irish people in general are
optimistic
you'd have to be
[ __ ] rain
[Music]
wherever i go i meet an irish person
everybody knows everybody it's like an
irish equivalent of gaydar
paddy dar
irish star i don't know but it works
i never know the difference between an
immigrant and immigrant oh the irish are
here oh great the irish are they they're
fine they're not like immigrants every
three decades are there abouts we export
roughly a half a million people
why are we such natural immigrants we've
been conditioned to move for a very long
time
i think it has to be about choice that
the bit that we have to try to end if we
can is that people have to leave for
economic reasons
in the 21st century ireland like many
countries is seeking to brand itself
brand ireland is so important
internationally for us and how we
promote
and how we talk about ireland
the base of ireland has changed you
don't have to have red hair and freckles
irish identity is very divorce martial
reality the only reason people buy into
this version of ourselves is because
they think that it is authentic and they
think it's authentic because we tell
them that it is when you're done with
your shamrocks and layla's come see the
real ireland
[Music]
be a country of six million with certain
strengths is a good thing to be a
diaspora of 70 million and engaging it
that's even stronger on doing the damage
created by
an inauthentic exploitative hypocritical
relationship countries have to market
themselves to their diaspora and the
diaspora becomes part of a large market
this may not be the way that countries
want to describe it but this is what
they're doing
[Music]
so
[Music]
well it was always known as the land of
opportunity and
the opportunity is still there
i remember getting off the plane in
sydney and i said to myself hmm
this is where i'm going to live
i love australia and
i like the people here i like the
weather
[Music]
unfortunately more than anything else
right and kumor set up their business
here
and i've been very fortunate to be part
of the business
[Music]
my name is michael kirwan i am the
general manager of coolmore australia
this is a 9000 acre farm it's
principally a breeding farm
cool more itself is enormous really it's
a the biggest commercial breeding and
racing operation in the world
it started out in ireland obviously in
the 70s
it was a partnership of john wagner
robert sangster and vincent o'brien
and their aim in those days was to
buy yearlings that would eventually turn
into champion racehorses and then they
would obviously go to stud then and
become champion sires and it's worked
out really well
have any issues down here or anything
though not really it's pretty straight
forward down here okay i wish these
bloody flies will go away
[Music]
we roughly have up to 150 people working
here
it's very important that we have the
right people working here especially
with the caliber of horse that we have
we're just walking into one of the
stallion barns here now
as you can see they're all pretty
relaxed
sort of having their afternoon siesta
which is good
here on my right is a horse called
adelaide he was a
cox plate here this in 2014. the weight
for age champion race here in australia
he's by one of our champion stallion one
of the best islands in the world in
galileo so he's an irish bred horse it's
all about
stallions producing race horses
we've been here for roughly 20 years now
and um
we've been very fortunate in that we've
stood
three champion stallions here in notably
dane hill in costa delago and fastnet
rock
and well fastened rock is a product of
cool more itself and he was bred
here
and fortunately we didn't sell him as a
yearling he was a champion racehorse as
a three-year-old
and went to stud with a very big
reputation covered some excellent mayors
in these first when he went to stood
first first two or three crops
and subsequently
those are turned into
champion racehorses so he's been a
success story from the day he was born
here
arguably the best stalin in australia at
the moment
i think we've stood
the champions are in australia
nine over the last 15 years people say
it's the look of the irish is it look at
the irish there's a bit of that involved
obviously right but i think it's more
that
the brand that the irish horseman has
there right is recognized all over the
world whether it be here in australia
new zealand america europe or wherever
it's just recognized as being a very
very good brand
irish people horsemen that's what it's
all about
[Music]
a brand is a proxy for a person it's an
identity that's created through the
delivery of products and services
[Music]
you know originally there was a
relationship between a customer and
the owner of a company or a store as
product
development and industrialization
gained scale the
concept of a brand was created so that
you could establish trust
between a manufacturer and
a consumer
the wild atlantic way is the longest to
find coastal drive in the world
it is a journey shaped and inspired by
the invading sea
by the defiant land that battles it
and by the native irish that enrich this
unique region
many countries are now involved in
national branding they're doing this
because there's a sense they have to
market what is different what is
distinctive what is unique about their
country
ireland has much that it can brand but
its starting point i think is the
character of the nation and the
character of the people that is also
reflected in how it reaches out to its
diaspora
who gets to define what it is
is it people telling you who they are
or is a brand frankly how other people
see you
ten years ago you could say that it was
important to brand
ireland within the context of the celtic
tiger
we know how that turned out
the biggest mistake of my professional
career was a paper that i wrote in 1998
and it was called nation brands of the
21st century and this was when i first
had the idea um that the in the age of
globalization and international trade
the images of countries had probably
become their most valuable asset
[Music]
the message that i sent out to
governments way back in the 90s was
whether you like it or not you're not
just policy makers anymore you're also
brand managers
i coined this term nation brand but the
problem was that this somehow got
twisted into nation branding
and you may well say well what what
difference can three letters possibly
make but actually they make a big
difference because nation brand just
means reputation is important nation
branding sounds like a promise it sounds
like a promise that if you don't happen
to like the image that you think your
country has got then you can magically
fix it with some
with some diabolical trick and now
nation branding is everywhere and it's
here to stay ireland both benefits from
and maybe in some ways not so much so
from the perceptions or less polite term
the stereotypes about this country
abroad i think it's also true that
ireland has sometimes perpetuated these
especially through its marketing
in much of the 20th century but ireland
is trying to really make up its mind
what it is for the rest of the world
is it this green pastoral country where
maids meet at the crossroads
or is it this high-tech urban space
where you can do business in the 21st
century the truth of course it's both
but to be able to market both at the
same time can be quite a challenge my
sense is that the ireland brand
is much bigger and long-standing than
any single point in time in any
generation
and that really the irish brand is a
accumulation of sorts
of all that's gone before
and largely i think the brand for
ireland is is quite good and quite
positive
[Music]
[Music]
there's no [ __ ] time for dilly
dallying on the ball no time for
scratching your mickey if you're walking
[ __ ] get your finger on your ass you
can do this i know you can have it in
you so that's what we're gonna do for
the next match also anyone would like to
buy cheap sunglasses
and i've also got a rather nice
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh today we're in shanghai to uh welcome
the 20th uh flexo asian gaelic games and
the number of teams we have here 65
teams all from 15 to 16 countries they
range from some countries middle east to
abu dhabi dubai
to japan to the philippines
to singapore hong kong everywhere
there's an irish person there's a team
[Music]
different generations that went on
immigration
that took the games
and here this weekend they're
flourishing in asia at the moment
it's fabulous to see here behind us the
team from tokyo one irish girl in the
restaurant from from tokyo all japanese
but if we keep playing our football
we'll get chances with monchi may aki
island all right so just keep it simple
you see more and more people now in the
ga clubs who have no irish connection
whatsoever because the irish have always
been an open and accommodating race the
irish people are welcoming people they
are very nice i play jay for uh
for fun just to for fun it's kind of
nice to be able
to use your strength a little bit about
against people which we can't usually do
in women's sports it's good to get to
know people as well from
home when you're abroad ga says a lot of
things about irish culture and i suppose
if you look even here today you can show
that it brings people together and i
love the game it's unique it's very fast
you can pick it up with your hands you
can keep goes there's no upside you know
it's so amazing such a lovely thing
everyone's just here to have a bit of
fun which is kind of what most irish
people are about
[Music]
a lot of things didn't come easy you
know to us and
we've had to struggle
we've had to struggle with the journey
of survival
[Music]
the epicenter 160 years ago was the
famine this incredible catastrophe
almost wiped us out
that was certainly the big driving piece
of the irish as a moving people the
irish as the people who
if in fact things aren't going well at
home you leave
[Music]
immigration has become instead of being
a last resort which it is for most
people in the world for the irish but
certainly an early resort and sometimes
the first resort
[Music]
every immigrant is a leader is a risk
taker is a change maker and they make a
huge contribution to their adopted
countries
every 30 years we've exported half a
million people a significant percentage
of a very small population there is this
view that sociologists and historians
have that official ireland has an
ambivalent relationship to irish
immigration
that it is a rebuke to the state that so
many young people leave that it is an
affront also to the state because these
people are voting with their feet and
saying i can do much better elsewhere
thank you very much and departing
irish politicians like to talk about the
brain drain the hemorrhage of the
brightest and the best but on the other
hand there's the sense also that we're
dispensing with
a rabble of a kind the people who if
they'd stayed might have rocked the boat
might have been less content with the
status quo so there's a kind of a sigh
of relief and we're very slow to
acknowledge the extent to which this
state could not have survived without
the generosity of immigrants but despite
the huge distances many irish graduates
can't envisage staying at home
it's estimated up to 200 000 irish
people will emigrate over the next five
years
even with the 85 billion euro bailout
we had this major downturn since 2008.
we lost people from a lot of trades and
a lot of professions if people want to
leave because they want to expand their
horizons they're restless they want to
see a bit of the work that's great that
the bit that for me we have to try to
end if we can is that people have to
leave for economic reasons here at the
clinton institute we undertook a study
on behalf of the department of foreign
affairs
and that study was set up to look
primarily at a program that the
department has run called the immigrant
support program and it was set up to
help the vulnerable irish
so the program really is established to
reach out to the diaspora to show that
ireland has a sense of care and duty in
relationship to that diaspora and i
think that's a very important message to
send to your immigrants abroad
the day in which immigration became a
diaspora
is a really really interesting moment
because diaspora suggests forced
displacement it suggests
a much
warmer less problematic relationship
with the homeland
the returned immigrant
is in a very unusual position roshini
unifeina is an enormously irish thing
which is pining for something that
frankly while you're off over there that
stopped
you lost your place in the queue
and you shouldn't expect that you're
just going to get back in there
good luck to the diaspora myself
included but ireland is moving on
[Music]
[Music]
growing up my family was just incredibly
enthralled with the election of john
kennedy as president i mean at that
point there had never been
an irish catholic elected president
united states
all of us regardless of our age were
very inspired growing up by the kennedys
in particular great looks like we're set
remind me before the days out that i've
got to
figure out who else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're in west seattle and we're in an
area that's called the junction the
junction is sort of the shopping streets
of of this part of seattle i grew up a
little distance on aokai beach which is
seattle's original neighborhood and at
that time this was very much of a
working-class neighborhood
folks like my father worked down at the
bottom of west seattle in a steel mill
my mother's
parents immigrated from
federer and temporary and from
patrick swell and limerick my father's
family a little further back are from
the north from
new orleans county down and from from
belfast
the irish came to this country and had
an opportunity to be anything they
wanted and then of course i think given
our tradition um the suffering there is
a real commitment i think on the part of
irish americans to social justice and to
others it just is one of the things you
see again and again
[Music]
[Applause]
this is great
nice to meet you i haven't walked
through these doors since the 1960s
excuse me uh junior high seventh eighth
graders
if you could just stop uh your
what you're working on what you're doing
um this is mayor marie so i came by
because i went to holy rosary elementary
and back in those days all the teachers
were nuns so things have changed a
little bit i can tell what's one of your
largest worries as a man
my largest worry as a mayor well there
really there are a couple things one is
we obviously have despite all of our
efforts we have a homeless problem that
is just growing and growing and i'm very
very concerned for the folks who are
homeless
uh that we can find a way to to deal
with this problem the other is um you
know we have issues particularly among
young men in this city around gun
violence and that worries me a great
deal those are that's a very good
question is it hard to be mayor
uh you know at times it is most days
it's great i get to meet so many
different people
just a week ago when the president was
here he asked me to ride in his car with
him so i got to ride in the presidential
limousine
[Music]
seattle and washington state and ireland
have a huge economic tie that is often
not understood but you know ryanair is
the largest purchaser of boeing planes
in europe and
microsoft's headquarters european
headquarters is in ireland
you know when i'm around the world and i
run into
irish irish born i have a connection and
i think they have a connection so it's a
great it's a great thing
it's uh
it's a very very
moving thing
[Music]
when i come to er
i feel whole
the erratas is a cultural festival but a
cultural festival with a difference
there's music the song does dance
non-stop from early morning
we unashamedly proclaim that we are an
irish language festival this is a
festival for irish language speakers
[Music]
my name is lima milia i'm a director of
eraktus nukelge and i was born and
raided in clendolcon in dublin world of
raptors means a gathering or coming
together of people for common purpose
we've been doing it for over 100 years
[Music]
in the last number of years we've had a
huge amount of people come home from
abroad for the festival some of these
are people who are born and rarely in
ireland some people come from canada and
from different parts of europe and
england
why would an artist who speaks nothing
with the irish language produce better
quality artwork
simply because they work through that
language why is it even different
it roots them it anchors them it puts
them back in a place and defines them
and holds them to that place and to
their people
my name is louis de puert and i'm from
cork i am an irish language writer and
the director of the center for air
studies at the national university of
ireland in galway
there are several aspects it seems to me
to the irish language i feel that when
i'm speaking irish or when i'm reading
irish i'm coming closer to that
historical experience it's not that you
can directly annex that experience to
the irish language but you can at least
come closer to what it seems to me than
you would in english
every language i think changes the way
that you relate to the world even
physiologically the way you shape your
mouth the way your tongue moves is
different
so if it affects us physiologically then
it seems likely that it affects us in
other ways as well
i feel a certain
kinship with people based on the fact
that they speak our interest in the
irish language despite the fact that we
would have explosively different views
on religion and politics and virtually
everything else under the sun
flynn o'brien famously said that if it
were not the case that the patterns of
the irish language suit us better than
any other language the language simply
wouldn't have come into existence nar
would have survived over two millennia
my name is maureen
and i come from lettermore in county
galway and i now live in boston for the
past 28 years
well i'm what you call a shadow singer
it is a story being told in a unique
musical
[Music]
way it has been passed on orally for
generations
so i feel that if i'm not doing that i
might as well not be alive
it courses through my veins it's my life
bloody
[Music]
so ireland has been described as the
laboratory of empire the the british
empire that is in the 17th century there
is a renewed understanding of the extent
to which
language and
cultural difference can provide a basis
for resistance to english colonial rule
in ireland the speech being irish the
heart must needs be irish to speak a
different language is to be disloyal so
that irish cultural nationalism with its
emphasis on language is conditioned as a
response to cultural colonialism which
is what may which which is what made
language explosive
radical resistant in the first place so
if you're mobilizing resistance then
quite clearly the language is going to
be foregrounded in that and that has
made the language much more divisive
in the 20th century than it would have
been
at earlier periods in our history
[Music]
we're at a critical moment where it
seems to me that not only the language
itself but these art forms are on the
brink of extinction
people talk about have been forced to
learn irish i think the real tragedy was
that some people were forced to teach
irish
[Music]
statistics
make for very grim reading there are
only some 76 000 people who speak the
irish language every day and a little
over 20 000 of those speak irish in
communities where it remains the first
language of everyday social interaction
that means it's likely that irish as a
living community language will not
survive the present generation
ireland i think needs to hold
its own identity
and not
bend
or conform
to anyone else's dream of how our
society should be
the challenge remains how do you
activate the latent passive knowledge
and very dynamic affinity that a great
many people have with the irish language
how do you provide opportunities for
people to speak the language and the
argument really is that we have never
provided those opportunities outside of
the classroom
there's a lot that's worth fighting for
[Music]
there's a great pride in culture in in
this country and to reimagine it
re-envision it blend it fuse it with
other cultures be it in literature or in
music
or in theater in acting
in visual arts
we do
make a lot of noise for a very small
country in that field and we are highly
regarded
my name is moya darty i am a producer
everybody's hugely proud of riverdance i
know when we go to china it's one of the
brands that's most known there and if
you say you're from ireland they say our
river dance and that makes people feel
really good about themselves and about
their culture because we are a small
island on the edge of europe and it is
something that defines us
it is great to find something that
defines you as a country
and that makes your brand brand ireland
stand out among the others
[Music]
so in excess of 25 million people have
seen it live
um oh over a billion have seen it on
tv the original
dvd sold over 10 million copies cd sold
over 3 million so our statistics are
pretty strong
touring
is really tough um you have to be young
you have to be fit you have to really
want it so there are sacrifices but most
of them are young they do it for five or
six or seven years of their life they
have a ball and then they go on and do
something else when they're dancing
years are over
[Music]
in business today geography is history
from eight o'clock in the morning in
china to six o'clock in the evening in
california
that's a 26-hour day and ireland is
right in the middle of that
[Music]
i travel a lot i spend a lot of time in
asia and in the us
and you hear very positive feedback
about ireland especially coming from
abroad
[Music]
liam casey i'm from cork and i'm the
founder and ceo of pch
[Music]
i had an idea i
spent a year working for a trading
company in california and i decided i'd
come home to ireland
because i knew there was an opportunity
in bringing technology products from
asia into the manufacturing
companies in ireland
then i decided i'd go to china because
everyone was telling me that's where
most of the factories were
the characters and the language were
very different and so it was pretty hard
to recognize it so you really depended
on
communicating with people
we're a product innovation company where
we take ideas
for products for physical products and
bring them all the way from the idea all
the way through to a product that shifts
into a consumer's hands
totally we have about 2800 people
parkers are headquarters in china is our
operations center and in san francisco
it's we have our innovation hub
a big part of what we do in the company
is we try to create a platform that
helps
these startups to be successful we want
to give them the best chance of being
successful possible and to do that we
give them all of our learning from the
last 19 years and it's been a phenomenal
success if it can be imagined it can be
made
and as a species what's propelled us
forward over tens of thousands of years
is our ability to create
technology from our hands from basic
wood implements and stone implements to
the wheel to the steam engine to the
smartphone
but we're all curious about about the
future and about change
my name is patty cosgrave i'm the
founder of the website
the web summit is a conference there's
about 21 and a half thousand people will
fly in from more than 100 countries
around the world to hear some of the
most
incredible tech entrepreneurs and
engineers and inventors and creators and
thinkers
talk and they'll also get to enjoy pub
crawls and nights out
we're all very young and our experience
before we'd organized the web summit was
going to some conferences but going to a
lot of music festivals and the music
festivals we really enjoyed and the
conferences that we went to we found a
little bit kind of stale and maybe a
little bit too stiff
and so we wanted to do something
different
the philosophy of the web summit i think
can be summed up in three words it's
people
pints
and physics
the growth of the web summit has been
propelled
to a large degree by a group of
physicists we take a very different
approach to building networks we see it
in conferences as a technical and
mathematical challenge and people find
themselves over the course of the next
four nights on on pub crawls or at
dinners or at meetings
and those meetings aren't random we
don't just pick out of a hat who's to go
on what pub crawl um instead instead we
build algorithms and try and find out as
much as we can about you and the types
of people you would like to meet
and then we optimize for that
algorithmically and the results have
been
incredible
this is a whole brand new data set which
is driving a huge amount of innovation
we all are in search of changing the
world in some way
it's like a playground for artists i
think entrepreneurs are really like
artists artists even the greatest
artists in the world spend their entire
lives painting and trying to create
something and eventually when they
create an incredible masterpiece
they're almost not happy so much so that
they have to go and continue to paint
the next masterpiece so many artists
continue to paint until the day that
they die never quite satisfied with what
they have created and they're obsessed
with the process or the journey
not with the destination
[Music]
the island of the welcome thing is a
very handy brand to tell people the
world that you'll come here we'll be
delighted to see you we're thrilled sure
you're shopping if you're buying things
uh you're buying iron jumpers and
whatnot like whatever i don't think we
let you into our hearts that much though
americans for example have this
very
polished politeness but actually jenny
would tell you stuff about themselves
you know you'll meet an american within
five minutes you'll find out about their
alcoholic grandmother and about how
they've just recently got into remission
or something like on the property you'd
be like ah as an artist you're going
jesus i don't want you telling me this
stuff i'm not gonna tell you anything
[Music]
comedy is a good example of brand irish
there are a number of irish comedians
there's a healthy number of irish
comedians but there's by no means some
outstanding no we aren't by any stretch
imagine the funniest people in the world
the key to the irish expressing how
successful they are is simply this right
three things make a list and a list
sounds like proof
so if you say
irish has the greatest music in the
world and you find two other bands to
name after you two
you're done people go oh you're right
you're right you're right you know
it makes no sense at all like i mean
because somebody'll go well hang on
who's the fourth on that list you'll go
do you know i difficulty come up with
two and three
pubs pubs are our beach head this is a
weird thing that we've created we don't
have a cuisine per se but we have a
style of drinking and we have a kind of
wooden context to do it in
one thing we have is we have an
informality about ourselves which
stands and varies to most places we're
quite brusque with each other in a jokey
friendly way we kind of know each other
enough even when we don't know each
other to be able to joke like that and
it does tend to mean that we make very
easy introductions to each other we're
very relaxed around each other the irish
that means good night outs but it also
means that you know we've left the
formal etiquette around us that other
other nations have that's a difficult
thing to recreate in people and it is
the one thing which you would go it's a
pleasure to be irish when you meet
another person you kind of go ah
oh yeah
jobs were very much sought after
people that worked here at the brewery
tended to stay here for all of their
working lives
there's a lovely saying here in the area
that older women would whisper to
younger women
get yourself a guinness man because he's
worth money alive or dead because of the
guinness pension
housing was provided we had a medical
department that was established here way
back in 1870
and we have a lovely saying that
guinness really looked after employees
from womb to tomb and that is so true
because
employees even received a burial
allowance
my name is deirdre mcparland and i am
beginners archive manager
the guinness archive is dedicated to the
whole history of guinness so our
foundation document is released that
arthrogyn assigned on new year's eve way
back in 1759.
our trademark label and which we hold
the first printer's proof in the archive
dating back to 1862
contains the harp and arthur guinness's
signature and obviously the guinness
name
the harp has always been associated with
ireland and the guinness harp is based
on a 14th century brown beru harp which
is preserved in trinity college in
dublin
and when ireland became an independent
free state the irish government also
wanted the irish harp as the national
emblem but we actually had the harp
trademark as part of our trademark label
so next time you look at your euro coin
you will notice that the state arc is
flipped the opposite way to the guinness
harp
we have um records here of families that
worked here for four or five generations
so there was always the great sense of
community and working here at the
brewery
and the fact now that we have these
records within our archives these are
utilized on a daily basis from people
all over the world um as a first point
stop for family research and people are
really open and
they really you know tell you about
their own family history and it's a part
of the job that i just absolutely love
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're at the home of guinness in the
guinness storehouse it's an incredible
building it's actually the first
skyscraper in europe it's built in the
chicago style of architectures in fact
it's actually the biggest visitor
attraction in ireland we get over 1.2
million visitors every year all coming
to the home of guinness and we love that
we welcome them with open arms and
obviously with a nice pint of guinness
waiting for them
i'm gronyu wafer i'm from dublin in
ireland and i am global marketing
director for guinness
over nine million glasses of guinness
are sold every day around the world
guinness m is part of diageo and
across the globe we employ 37 000 people
and on guinness itself we have
operations brewing operations in over 40
countries
sold in over 150 countries around the
world it's actually brewed in over 40
countries around the world and wherever
you go from jakarta to lagos to new york
to galway and you will find somebody
enjoying a delicious guinness somewhere
in the world
one of the things that's always been
most famous about guinness is actually
it's advertising and it's been a real
part of how we've built the brand across
the world way back in 1929 when actually
advertising as an industry was almost
unknown the marketing guys at the time
went to rupert guinness and he set down
a kind of a challenge which has been our
challenge ever since which is you can
only make an advertisement if the
quality of the advertisement is as good
as the quality of our beer
[Music]
for for many people who are living um
away from home and away from ireland
actually one of the things they most
look forward to is getting back and and
having a point of guinness and they're
local with their friends and and that's
as much about how fantastic the quality
of the guinness is in that bar but also
i suppose by connecting back in with
ireland connecting back in with their
community connecting back in with their
friends and you know the pub is such a
fantastic place for all of that to
happen
[Music]
uh
[Music]
way to go you're doing all the work
today that's right now you know how i
feel on sunday morning
[Music]
i come from a little town in missouri
called baldwin little irish parish holy
when i was a kid i used to watch the st
patrick's day parade on fifth avenue i
used to say wow how great it must be to
be in new york in front of st patrick's
cathedral for st patrick's day parade
and now i'm the grand marshal you talk
about the irish dream and the american
dream come true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning sir
i have radios for all the guys i have
four additional radios and backup
batteries with me here
and right now i'm heading to the
cathedral
the real show starts uh once we come
back out from mass and a lot of planning
but
it comes comes together on the day and
that's all that matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a special day for us both for
the irish all over
your presence here helps us celebrate
this feast
with the dignity and the joy it deserves
and is making this mass all the more
festive and special
[Applause]
[Music]
security has to be on either side
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think everyone has a little irish
today i haven't worked on st patrick's
day in about 30 years
[Music]
happy st patrick's day
[Music]
the sensation when people come out and
turn onto fifth avenue and all you see
is a sea of humanity here celebrating
irish heritage and culture in new york
city it gives me goosebumps every year
[Music]
as far as most people are concerned out
there countries are either good or evil
so good countries are the ones that
people like
[Music]
my name is simon anholt i have an
unusual job i advise the presidents and
prime ministers and occasionally
monarchs of countries and i advise them
on all kinds of things but mainly
connected with how they and their
country can engage more productively
with other countries and with the rest
of the world
so around about 2013
i sat down with some
some friends from the university where i
pretend to be a professor and we try to
figure out how could you measure
the contribution that each country on
earth makes to
the global community to the planet and
to humanity in general
and that's where the good country index
came from so you've got these seven
individual rankings which give you each
country's position in the world
where it ranks in terms of its
contribution to the environment to
health and well-being to peace and
security to how well the world is run
what we call world order
and culture and science and technology
and things like that and then also very
controversially there's an overall
ranking which takes all seven of those
and averages them out so you then get a
master list of as far as we can tell
what is each country's contribution to
the world in general
the the big headline was the fact that
ireland came first ireland relative to
the size of uh the country's economy
which is how we normalize the the data
so the big countries don't get an unfair
advantage
contributed more to humanity and the
planet than any other country on earth
and this strikes me as being a beautiful
fact
we've had an incredibly severe
retrenchment of the irish economy we've
lost
just short of a fifth of our total
economic size
job cuts in the public sector are
forecast
cut in welfare and social welfare
of course ireland is preparing to suffer
one of the things that was most uh
creditable about ireland's results is
the fact that it comes top on 2010 data
and 2010 was the year in which ireland's
government debt was at its highest point
so there's something immensely moving
about the fact that this country managed
to instinctively probably remember its
obligations to the rest of mankind in
the moment of its greatest distress
but the reaction i got from ireland when
the good country index was first
published with ireland at the top was
mixed i think is the is the word to
describe it
i got a lot of very angry emails from
irish people
lots of them because
they had been going through and still
were going through an unbelievably hard
time
and they were worrying about whether
they were going to be able to feed their
children or not and suddenly this idiot
from england comes along and say oh it's
the goodest country on earth and it's
just the last [ __ ] straw
and the thing that i had to then start
to try to explain is actually this is
something you should be proud of
and it doesn't mean that your government
at that time was spending more money on
foreigners than on the needy irish it
doesn't mean that their attention was
distracted by overseas business when
they should have been thinking about
their own people in their own country it
means if more countries were like
ireland the world wouldn't have half the
problems that it's facing today
[Music]
my name is christina noble i was born in
the liberties in dublin i was in the 40s
and
it was kind of a rough place to be born
at that time
mommy died when i was 10.
my father was a chronic alcoholic so
i was an orphan
and one of
six children
eventually we were all split up and sent
into different institutions
it was a hard life i'm not going to
pretend otherwise it just was a very
hard life
to be ripped apart from your brothers
and sisters and
not knowing where anybody was going or
what's happening
it's
horrific it's
it's beyond any words
jumped out of a big high window from the
institution
so i was a child on the run
hiding like a rat would hide
i slept in the parks the streets i
didn't know what the next day was going
to bring
i lived off leaves
bread that would be left in the bins
i had candle grease from the churches
i've had in cardboard i experienced the
most horrendous horrific stuff in my
life
there were times i wanted to die
really dying
so
in a sense my childhood has been
if you like a kind of education
albeit a different education
in helping me to be
the person i am today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i first came to vietnam
in 1989
i found a whole country of kids living
on the streets
with little hope for a better future
i wanted to create a place where the
children could go to school and have the
right education which would give them
choices later on in life
i started the christina noble foundation
over 25 years ago
we have established the sunshine school
a primary school for the underprivileged
we run the largest free health care
clinic in the whole of ho chi minh city
we currently work with
about a thousand kids a day you cannot
trust people you don't know okay you
cannot you don't talk you
walk fast away
fast okay
if you don't feel comfortable
if somebody gives you a hug
don't do it just say no thank you okay
god bless you all
dear grandmother
i don't mind i am a grandma
i love you we have irish we have uh
australia we've had african people
working with us where are you from you
got irish in you my mum's from
uh black rock around on leary oh do you
hear my mom's black ralph posh
all nationalities all nationalities
they say there's a little bit of irish
in everybody's heart you can't tell me
that we can't all work together
thousands of kids who have a chance to
grow up happy and healthy
we still have a long way to go
nothing is impossible guys
we all forget that love is very powerful
it's something
we have that weapon inside of us
that weapon to love
to share love and be loved
and it doesn't cost anything
and it doesn't destroy the atmosphere
it doesn't destroy mankind it makes it
better
and if you think i'm talking silly
try it sometime
[Music]
the culture and the society
that isn't changing
is dying
i think
the irish do get out there and get stuck
in but i think the irish have had to
through famine through conflict through
recession
[Music]
we're just constantly having to leave
the country
i think one of the big questions for us
those was the care about the place is
like well so what do we want ireland to
look like at 100 and i think there's a
big opportunity for us to have that
debate right now
in this age of globalization our jobs
are changing our sense of identity is
changing our sense of our nation's state
is changing our sense of the
relationship between here and elsewhere
is changing and that is a world in which
i think the irish will flourish we are
the natural immigrants
there's a new form of irishness
beginning to emerge
[Music]
people are seeing us as we are
your sense of being irish is also a
sense of being global ireland is
understanding the power of networks and
also understands the power of its own
very special network the irish diaspora
i see a new paradigm emerging whereby we
in ireland you can say we can be the
custodians of your heritage and your
identity and then they in their turn can
be our pathfinders and supporters and
allies in in a complex global world
no matter what iteration it takes over
time brand ireland is always about
optimism
overcoming the odds
remaining cheerful
and remaining determined
circumstances and decades can change
exactly how it's branded but to me
that's the essence of what ireland is
and and probably what it will
remain
in the merry month of june from me home
i started left the girls of june nearly
broken hearted salute to father dear
kiss me darling mother drank a pint to
bear me grief and here's the smother
then after eat the corn leave where i
was born cut to stealth like turn to
banish ghosts and goblins a brand new
pair of brogues rattling nor the bugs
frightening all the dogs on the rocky
road to double and one two three four
five
that night i rested limp so weary
started by daylight me spirits sprite
and there he took a drop of the pure
keep me heart from sinking that's the
paddy's cure whenever he's on for
drinking jesse the lassie smile laughing
all the while at me curious touch would
set your heart to bubbling and asked if
i was hard wages i required till i was
nearly tired of the rocky road to double
it one two three four five hund the hair
and turn her down the rocky road all the
way to double and wack for lolly ra
in dublin next arrived i thought it's
such a pity to be so soon deprived of
you of that fine city well then they
took a stroll dull among the quality
bundle it was stole all in a neat
locality something crossed me mine when
i looked behind the bundle could i find
upon me stick a wobble and enquire him
for
my spirits never fail and landed on the
cage just as the ship was sailing the
captain at me roar said the door of
hattie when i jumped aboard a cabin
found for paddy down among the pace
played some honey rings dance some
hearty jigs the water
down the rocky road all the way to
double and whack for lolly ride